we watched South Park we watch Family
Guy it's time for American Dad let's see
these medical scenes if they're legit or
not huge thank you to Dropbox for
sponsoring a portion of this video
the world needs anti-venom Steve think
of how many lives we'll save I think the
numbers something out of this world like
a hundred thousand people I've read
somewhere that lose their lives to snake
bites so anti-venom is incredibly
important but you know anti-venom works
on the same principles that vaccines
work we give animals the Venom they make
antibodies we get that serum and we use
it as anti-venoms
now hold up a second I want to make sure
we got a good one
there's experts out there that based on
the size of the snake the color of the
snake the pattern of its
casing for lack of better word scales
and the shape of its head they'll make a
call on what kind of snake it is or what
anti-venom you need I have no idea what
this is I would describe it as an
orangey yellowy anger snake
ow it's him and he nipped me oh my God
quick grab his tail
okay all right right now they're already
breaking the first rule of snake bite
the first rule of snake bite sounds like
Fight Club is get away from the snake
that's literally the first thing not
pick it up and bring it with you oh
that's a lot of bites
why are they bagging it just run away
from it get medical help now if you
don't get anti-venom in like the first
three four hours it's a problem because
the damage can be already be done
remember anti-venom neutralizes the
Venom so if the venom has already done
the damage it's not going to reverse
that damage wait did it Steve
this is evil to laugh at but you know
there's some misinformation that comes
about when it when people talk about
snake bites I learned about this in like
a Wilderness lecture don't do the suck
out Venom trick it's going to introduce
more bacteria maybe even give you more
Venom into your mouth don't bleed the
area don't raise it above your heart
because that's actually gonna make it
drain into your heart try and stay calm
and get help immediately that's like the
number one thing you need to do because
it's about the anti-venom is it
anti-venom or Anti-Venom
anti-venom how would you say it write in
the comments
oh with syllables
dad have you seen Jeff he never came
home last night oh yeah he volunteered
himself for a deadly experimental
surgery at the CIA what why didn't you
stop him I guess I don't care whether he
lives or dies experimental treatments
are so important for us as humans and I
encourage people to sign up for trials
because there are ethics boards that
prevent them from going too far but I
don't know if I could actually recommend
that as a doctor like that sounds
antithetical to my training
up this atrocity at once oh okay
applesauce here as Jeff's legal guardian
you need to sign this release before I
can do the operation intelligence
enhancement
Curiosity has this worked on any of your
test animals there's one Goose that's
now in Mensa
what's the score of IQ that you need for
men's is it like 140 150. did I get it
right this time doc oh my God you have
your gown on backwards you're supposed
to have it open to the other way I mean
I guess it depends on what you're trying
to do hopefully here to stop me from
doing this super dangerous thing
he's all yours doc oh
[Music]
oh no what are they doing a cranial
surgery of some kind
are they uploading the internet into his
brain as a doctor I will tell you that
is not feasible although with how much
time you've been spending on Tick Tock I
will say you're getting close did it
work let's find out
which of the little people is wearing
his hospital gown correctly the left
this one
seems to have had a bit of a sartorial
snafu I just realized on the back of the
thing his diplomas is hard word
back to the show in just a second but
first I want to thank Dropbox for
sponsoring this part of the video if you
watch my channel before then you know I
don't do this all by myself I may sit in
front of the camera and say the words
but so much of the production and
editing work is done by the rest of my
team and while Dan might be sitting
behind the camera we've actually got
team members all around the world so it
was important to me to find an efficient
way to communicate with my International
staff that's why I've been so happy with
Dropbox capture which allows me to get
my message to my team across screenshots
gifs or simple videos recorded right on
my screen here's how it works I've
recently been developing new merch with
my designer Caroline what I used to do
is receive an image of her design and
then write her a lengthy email detailing
what changes I wanted her to make with
Dropbox capture I don't need to write
this long and confusing message because
I can quickly record myself and my
screen simultaneously mark it up with
areas that I specifically want changed
and then send it over for her to watch
on her own time gone are the days of
struggling to find a time for us to hop
on a call or having to make sense of
verbose emails it makes it so easy for
me to say what I mean without scheduling
anything get your message across clearly
and quickly with Dropbox capture
download and try it today for free by
clicking on the link in my description
box below huge thanks to Dropbox for
sponsoring this part of the video let's
get back to the show one two three
[Music]
you raised a lightweight in general
women have a harder time processing
alcohol a lot of times this is due to
body size and body habitus but it could
also be due to a lower amounts of the
enzyme that breaks alcohol down known as
alcohol dehydrogenase ultimate Kelly's
what's what's in it don't worry about it
that's a lot of drinks this is an
example of binge drinking and something
you shouldn't do and I wonder if that's
um absent and does it have true wormwood
in it wormwood does make you hallucinate
but I think modern absent doesn't have
wormwood in it anymore honey you sit
this one out they don't call it the
kidney killer for nothing I mean if you
drink alcohol to this extent it could be
a kidney killer not only does it raise
your blood pressure which damages your
kidneys but it also affects your heart
which damages your circulation which
damages the kidneys but it also damages
the liver and chronic liver failure can
impact your kidneys so it's like a one
two three KO on the kidney
oh here we go the ab muscles take you
back
oh take you back that's so cool that her
kidneys sing my Never sing what's the
matter the alcohol
I can't take it anymore Joe I'm I'm
shutting down you could get a cute uh
kidney injury from drinking too much
alcohol usually acute kidney injury does
resolve if you stop drinking the alcohol
and rehydrate appropriately over time
it's chronic kidney injuries where you
get in trouble CKD goodbye Joe I'll
always remember that trip we took to the
anus
your kidneys do not go to your anus
solar system joke inseam always at 20
inches you telling me I'm not growing at
all
at all check on pediatric visits like we
have a growth chart that we plot as
children age that you're really trying
to see what percentile children are in
not so much how fast they grow but are
they still staying on that same
percentile or at least close to it
because imagine you have a child that's
on the 50th percentile 50th percentile
and all of a sudden they drop off and
they're below the 10th percentile now
all of a sudden you need to investigate
why that's happening what can I do for
you today little buddy you want to do
something about that skin
I'm here because it's come to my
attention that I am not growing this by
the way looks exactly like all
pediatricians offices you'll want to
know the secret to growing get lots of
sleep eat lots of veggies and always
remember your inner worth because
that'll make you feel ten feet tall oh
okay I would have left that last corny
bit out but the rest of it sounded
really good and the reason sleep's so
important here is because only with
adequate sleep does your hormonal system
function optimally we're talking about
growth hormone testosterone for this
gentleman March couldn't be done about
your heart are you familiar with the
Abominable Sciences you know there is a
doctor who I'm seeing pop up across Tick
Tock and other social media selling a
procedure for limb lengthening and
initially this procedure was really
created for limb straightening for those
who had uh bowed legs now it's being
used to increase height by basically
fracturing the legs with nails on top
and bottom spreading them out
millimeters and then allowing the bone
to heal and and doing that over and over
again to me it sounds Draconian I I
don't know would I ever in my life
recommend that to somebody because if
you are struggling with your confidence
or your mental health and you think two
inches of height added is gonna solve
that for you it's not the two inches of
height that's going to solve it for you
that's my thought process one of my
success stories I used to be six inches
tall now I'm daddy's favorite look at me
walk
[Music]
you know what's funny surgeons do listen
to really loud usually dramatic music
when they operate Steve there's
something I have to show you when I was
a boy I used to carve my height here on
the bark this extra deep one is from a
few years where I didn't grow at all
it's called The Smith's stall but
eventually I shot up six inches growth
spurts happen at different ages like for
me I went into high school 6-3 and then
never grew
doctor we
should be in here
let's go we're thirsty too we want
orange juice now my apologies but a
hospital can't allow their violent
patients to run about freely and what
that mean a better life through
lobotomies oh no you know Russia was one
of the first countries to make
lobotomies illegal and then the U.S
ended up following suit uh when it comes
to psychosurgery but you know
psychosurgery is still used uh to this
day in some very specific evidence-based
cases most notably making a severance
for epilepsy that's drug resistant in
the corpus callosum which is the
connection between the two sides of the
brain actually the person who created
lobotomy's won the Nobel Prize for it
and then a lot of people have requested
that the Nobel organization retrieve it
because they think it's too
controversial tens of thousands of these
were performed with like very few
evidence
ew look at Steve Smith is it supposed to
be curved like that hey it candy get
that thing straightened out
well what are they talking about it's
not curved is it fellas all right first
I'm not looking down and second they're
talking about your spine you've got
scoliosis were they talking about a
spine and you can't really tell
scoliosis from that far away so like I
don't buy that I mean you can if you
could tell that one shoulder is higher
than the other one of the hips is higher
than the other or maybe if even one of
the rib angles is higher than one
another but then you could usually see
that only when a person bends over
pretty as a picture scoliosis what do we
do amputate actually all he needs is a
back support it really depends on
something known as the Cobb angle which
is after we order a certain type of
x-rays we can calculate this cob angle
and we see how bad the scoliosis is and
most of them really are just treated
with conservative management like
physical therapy in some cases we do
bracing in really advanced cases maybe
surgery is an option but that's only
when the curve is so bad that it's
compromising your ability to breathe or
your heart to beat properly is it like
one of those belts weight lifters wear
at the Olympics so they don't blow out
their rectums but that's now why weight
lifters wear those that looks terrible
and that's not what they wear I call her
the chick magnet ironically of course no
no girl wants any of that I'll tell you
why that device sucks
because you cannot take a deep breath so
what essentially is going to do is going
to cause you to splint your breathing
which means that you're not going to
take a deep breath which means that the
lower parts of your lungs the bases that
really take a lot of effort to fill
won't fill and therefore you will have
essentially a loss of the lower part of
your lung known as atelectasis Dad I
know it's only what's on the inside that
matters but I'm just not as strong as oh
you're bald
um um there's a kid on the football team
with cancer so the whole defensive line
shaved our heads in solidarity what yeah
that was just nonsense I'm bald I
actually shaved my head to stand in
solidarity with kids with cancer here's
a picture sorry you had to see this guys
we have huge news
oh
Steve you're gonna be an uncle I love
the goldfish
and what will I be oh Klaus
you'll be nearby
and dad you're gonna be a grandpa why
not make the Goldfish the the gold the
god fish
what
just keep smiling baby you don't get it
just keep smiling no I don't
everyone wants to be said yeah but the
god fish that's a bridge too far come on
God fish Godfather I think you're drunk
and it's a goldfish there's a lot of
yeah
objection I'm cooking breakfast for my
sweet daughter oh thanks Dad oh my God
please don't tell me he's gonna put some
kind of medication in there for her to
end the pregnancy no he's not
no
Jesus that's evil Jeff I wanted to take
you out to dinner to celebrate your
efforts to impregnate my daughter and
here we are at the restaurant
this place looks fancy a vasectomy is
basically a permanent usually near a
hundred percent effective form of birth
control for men and it's called the
vasectomy because it blocks or Cuts your
vast deference which is the tube that
carries sperm from your testicle to
your peen how big is your minestrone is
this man not aware he's here for a
medical procedure can you tell me a
little bit more about your colonoscopy
is that spicy no
I don't think this is the best place to
eat for someone with your cholesterol
absolutely not if you have high
cholesterol and you're eating foods with
high saturated fat content you're going
to run into troubles because your
cholesterol go even higher raising your
10-year risk score of having
ascvd Stan the doctor gave you this
health journal to monitor your Fitness
and eating habits hey if it ain't broke
don't fix it it's broke and you heard my
stool sample results too hard to test
that's not a thing but you're getting
older you need to take care of yourself
even when you're younger you should take
care of yourself because they'll pay
dividends for when you get older if he
doesn't change his lifestyle something
terrible Could Happen sadly people are
often set in their ways until something
really rattles them like a like a
near-death experience that's actually
true or a loved one who really cares for
them encourages them to seek care
with all the coffee after the amount of
cheese I consumed at Fuddruckers it
takes three pots worth just to get my
system running again that's too much
caffeine there the maximum caffeine we
say safe to have in a day is 400
milligrams and I will say there are
certain drinks like at Starbucks aventi
blonde roast has like 460 milligrams and
then people put espresso shots into
those so be careful you're gonna start
developing some heart arrhythmias if you
keep pumping that caffeine like that
these diseases I've literally only seen
in medical textbooks check out this
video lots of great medical commentary
as always stay happy and healthy
thank you